Since you’re already all here
Since you’re all here
Why don’t you tell me how it feels?
Tell me how it feels?
To be judging like a mother
Are you feeling high and mighty yeah?
Don’t touch me nah don’t touch me
You trynna save me but I got me yeah
I don’t need no intervention
I don’t need no
Cause it’s my call
And it’s my bad
So no white walls
and no 12 steps
It’s my decision
It's my decision
No intervention
Been blacked out, fell down, hurt loud,
but damn it if I ain’t proud cause I know how
To lose it all to find myself, go ahead call me a liar
I went to hell and I came back on fucking fire
You can call me a hot mess, but this is my process
It may not look pretty, but baby this is progress (yeah)
Gotta start from the bottom if you want that ascension
Did I forget to mention?
I don’t need no intervention
I don’t need no
Cause it’s my call And it’s my bad
So no white walls
And no 12 steps
It’s my decision
No intervention
I don’t need no intervention
No intervention no intervention, yeah yeah
It's my decision
No intervention